قد يكون فطورا تقليديا لكنه يحمل معه
تفاصيل الصباح رائحه خبيز التقليدي تجمعنا
معكم من الاردن وتخطية اي مسافات
صباح العربيه في طبق وانا اخترت طبق
الجريش السعودي المبتكر مع الريش المشويه
مع الشيف العالمي منصور اسماعيل
[موسيقى]
تحضير العجين بحب اول شرط من شروط اعداد
اقراص الزعتر البلدي
[موسيقى]
رائحه الزعتر وزيت الزيتون توثق الكثير من
ذكريات هذه الاقراص
[موسيقى]
طبقات من الزعتر والعجين تنتهي مرحله
تحضيرها الاخيره في الفرن لون الحمره يعني
النهايه اقراص الزعتر تجهزت لتعلن صباح
يوم جديد
[موسيقى]
اليوم راح نسوي الجريش الابيض لكن راح
نستخدم معاه الريش المقادير راح نستخدمها
طبعا حب الجريش رشه كمون بسيطه السمن
البصل والليمون الاسود هذا راح يكون
للحشوه اللي من فوق طبعا والمويه
[موسيقى]
ايش اعتمدته هيئته فنون الطهي طبقا وطنيا
للسعوديه انطلاقا من قيمته التاريخيه
والاجتماعيه والغذائيه الشيخ منصور
اسماعيل ساهم في اعداد كتاب سفره المائده
السعوديه بشراكه مع هيئه فنون الطهي
التابعه لوزاره الثقافه
الجيش الابيض بالريش طبق يليق بصباح
العربيه او اعيد العربيه العشرين والطبق
زي ما انتم شايفين يشكي ويحكي
[موسيقى]